the Joe Rogan experience when you see
combat sports today and you see like the
landscape of boxing I feel personally
that this is an amazing time I mean I
feel like the heavyweight division has
never been more exciting and more
turbulent because there's so many great
fighters now to have and Ruiz jump out
of nowhere and knock out Anthony Joshua
I think was a godsend for the sport
because all of a sudden you see like
look at this chubby Mexican just [ __ ]
up this dude looks like a god like this
is crazy like and this is for the
Mexican community it's huge having their
first Mexican heavyweight champion but
it's also like wow this is a crazy
division look you got the Deonte just
knocked the [ __ ] out of Luis Ortiz with
that one punch the forehead you like
what the [ __ ] you got the rematch with
Tyson Fury's coming up in two weeks
right not even right less than twenty
second oh my goodness now what you're
talking about earlier is exemplified and
what happened after the Ruiz fight where
you see like he's a chubby guy that's
very yeah but he's a [ __ ] fighter oh
my god he's a heavyweight hands be real
his hand speeds tremendous and if you
think just because he's chubby you can
take a knock of the guy especially after
he won the title as though he won the
lottery or he won a scratch-off and this
[ __ ] just happens it doesn't it reminded
people of what the heavyweight division
is one punch can change the fight is a
real thing it is a real thing he [ __ ]
up doing that rematch that rematch was a
disaster so he was so clearly unprepared
when he weighed 280 I was like oh my god
and what was the rumors like and I fell
into him too like everybody's talked
about how he's getting thinner and
Instagram picture I did with chubby
girls do held that camera well you know
he lost he wasn't training with his
trainer and he was partying a lot you
know and I knew he was partying a lot
heard from people that knew him they're
like man
I heard whistle that didn't believe it
like no [ __ ] I believed it I believed it
you know I believed it cuz it's so hard
not to all of a sudden you're the
[ __ ] man now nowhere and maybe he was
convinced that he could do it again
you know he's hitting the pads it looked
pretty good hitting the bag looked
pretty good as I [ __ ] that guy up
again but Anthony Joshua had a totally
different game playing this time and to
see Anthony Joshua stick and move like
that was interesting I was like wow yeah
that's interesting it's a cliche but it
again losing might have been the best
thing that ever happened to him I don't
know about that I don't know about that
you know I mean I think it's great that
he got his title back but I felt like
one thing that happened in that fight
that disturbed me was even though Ruiz
came in out of shape and clearly didn't
look like he was prepared correctly
Joshua didn't did never really enforce
his will on him he never really had a
moment was beating the [ __ ] out of him
was like you know I trained hard for
this fight
I'm gonna dominate you now now I'm gonna
take you out the way you took me out
there was none of that
it was boxing just stick and move make
sure you get the decision make sure you
get the decision that is in stark
contrast with Deonte finishes fights
which is why that matchup is so
intriguing which is why no matter what
happens between the two of them
hopefully they remain undefeated for
their own sakes and can they make that
unification fight I saw his commitment
to discipline Joshua I'm taught as a
good thing oh it's definitely a good
thing because he won the title back but
when you make the argument who's the
best heavyweight in the world if you
have to look at it on paper I don't
think it's him right now I think it's
Tyson Fury or Deontay Wilder depending
on what happens on the 22nd I lean
towards Deonte because he can close this
show at any moment that 12th round I was
I was in bed and I was watching the
fight and I went oh [ __ ] I popped up oh
[ __ ] he knocked him out he knocked and
then whoop Tyson Fury rising like what
the [ __ ] he rises he gets through the
barrage
and then he wins the remainder of the
round like this is insane and even rock
Deonte at one point I'm like this is an
insane fight and then it was a draw and
I don't think on paper it's really a
draw
I think that's horseshit I think on
paper Tyson Fury one more rounds but I'm
not upset with the draw because the way
Deonte knocked him down and then knocked
him down on the way he knocked him down
the third run in 12th round should
almost count for like three points I
mean it's so crazy just about any
there's not a criticism of Jack Reiss
like the guy did get up so you can't say
you know did something wrong but most
referees of that what is his weight
they're not most there's no were flat he
was laying on his back it looked like he
was in another dimension
can you think of any other fight and the
countless fights that you've covered
where the the main highlight of the
fight is just a guy getting up crazy
this is crazy
yeah hey crazy well that punch to the
right hand and the left hook behind it
and then him walking off like this he
thought he had him raised yeah Tyson
Fury is something special man but so is
Deonte
it shows Joshua like yes three of those
guys they're so uniquely different that
I can't say I mean I know who's best can
rage for days
but I don't know that for sure this guy
beats that guy that guy beats the other
guy this guy and that guy you know you
you won't know until they face each
other and what I'm saying is even if
Deonte were to lose to Tyson Fury I
still want to see Joshua Wilder that is
the fight I want to see that is the
fight I want to well I definitely the
rematch is the first fight I want to see
the next fight I want to see regardless
of the outcome is I want to see well
unless Tyson Fury caio's Wilder
have Tyson Fury kales Wilder it's like
an - a Joshua Anthony Joshua dosa
if he gets a Mike and starts talking
that kind of [ __ ] then I want to see
that fight but if my dream match up
right now is the rematch that's the
dream matchup the dream matchup is the
22nd yeah I am so [ __ ] pumped for
that rematch who I'm not doing jack [ __ ]
I'm gonna I'm taking the night off
I'm sitting right in front of the
[ __ ] TV sweaty palms
let's see for you to say that about a
boxing match that's a huge thing I love
boxing though I do I mean I call combat
sports you know I call MMA but I do love
boxing
[Applause]